hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back those 7 days to die we
had a little bit of a crisis silver
night I don't know if you guys saw you
might have seen if you know what I did
but anyway yeah so apparently zombies
were spawning in this cave down here so
I tried to plug up some holes and I'm
gonna dig less stupidly to try to make
it so that we can not die because not
dying is happens the better than dying
well that's not what I was going for
wait I was going for a GI Joe joke oh go
ahead GI Joe joke please go for it I
already did it oh good one cuz not dying
is half the cut go your way have to deal
your bull I'm gonna go with my totally
independently thought up plan and leave
you and go to the town good luck
thank you at least you have manner still
so I'm gonna do this thing that I
totally am spontaneously doing that we
didn't plan out and I'm gonna go to the
town and abandon you wait what you're
leaving will is obvious yes ah ah my
plan has come to fruition now you will
die
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha You Know Who I
am right there until I shoot you in the
leg
what why would you do that Rick is that
what your plan does not come to fruition
oh it's already going cuz I'm on my way
you kidding me
I'm strafing I'm strafing Oh David ok
anyway so now that we're not together
you're gonna have to be very descriptive
out what is happening ok well preferably
with what you can just watch the video
on my side yeah don't go there don't
click on Wade's face to click the
annotation to go over to his channel Oh
what's on the video what so don't click
the link that you put on the head don't
do that no don't do that please dear god
no it's horrible over there or something
I don't know so many people are not
gonna click it just cuz you said that no
they're gonna reverse psychology's very
powerful now they don't know what to do
because I said they were gonna do it
when they weren't now they don't know if
they're gonna do it if they don't do it
and if they don't do it they do do it in
if I tell them to do it they weren't
gonna do it anyway but then they did
tell them to not do it after I told them
to do it oh they're gonna do it oh man
there are so many zombies really tell me
more about the
in a really descriptive way I'm actually
gonna kill a deer instead please don't
or do I eat you need the meat you'd
really need to be did you figure out a
way to get clay I think clay isn't that
that like yellowish dirt it might be
yeah I don't know a lot of these things
crap so I'm only looking for food
correct uh primarily and is it foods but
primarily what we need and prodding is
I'm gonna get some water too if I can
find him put food and water is basically
my priority and anything else that I can
find got a can of tuna Wade that's good
idea that's good good for me okay a big
swarm of zombies it's probably about ten
of them later oh that's good we're good
thank you thank you for being with that
way
let's you're got lots of meat good job
good good job when you're so good god
you're the best
are you all in all the rest oh there's a
basement I found a basement can of thumb
or other dog food you'll eat that one
right oh yeah I've done it before I'm
not picky about it either in a survival
situation dog food is lots of protein
and other goodie goodie gumdrops goodies
I'm collecting loot off of the dead
zombies now yay good good always good
and I'm finding like ammo for shotgun
shells but no food that's no bueno
you're no bueno hi-yah I love pontius
toy un gato and meats back to low knees
with the pencil isolate you know people
often like correct me like it's not a
store you got oh that's just ridiculous
and I'm like it'll stay in the fact that
you don't care haha they really don't
like I try to explain them like I'm
trying to be as bad as possibly I know
it that means that I am a cat in my
pants that's what I'm going for
that's it Rick I'm making pants yeah I
am a cat in my pants that's amazing
tango play do estoy Ehlert way do I
don't know what at wound way do means I
don't either
I don't I don't think another streak
please continue arrow play do let's go
hey
what's going on doggy it was a doggy
that attacked me it's tagged me real
good boss shouting his face Paul that's
good that's good you did that
it's good you did that look I turned to
Christopher Walken it always goes back
to Christopher Walken Wow okay Tony
offer okay walking we're just walking on
sunshine oh oh oh oh oh oh oh I'm
walking on the grace sunshine Sun oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh I hear creepy noises I
hear a doggie
do you hear a doggie I listened but
zombies had burns on me what zombie
that's too funny hey wha
no silly he's not funny at all I just
found some Irishman is is noonish extras
almost one now so I'm gonna keep I'm
gonna come back at five tell me a story
wait once upon a time there was a fan
who wanted to know where markiplier was
okay so he emailed Marc's friend Wade
and said hey where's mark
it's a Wade not knowing where Mark was
told the funny little fan mark is in
Alaska feeding lemurs from his
pocketbook and the fan said oh okay
the end Wow gray story Wade that was
just amazing to show you how cuz that
story was oh I know wasn't it was Ash it
was a bunch of poofy ass chicks last
time mark ever asked me to tell us this
let's do a story you tell one line I'll
tell another line and we'll go back and
forth alright you start there was a man
named Rhonda and Rhonda was a
professional figure skater and she loved
to paint with her toes yeah but a lot of
people got bad attention because there's
those weirdos with foot fetishes out
there so she had to stop that so instead
she picked up uh nose picking
professionally and you know and in this
trust real applications nose-picking is
high demand market I don't have a lot of
junior plays uh and as she got better at
it people became concerned they're like
man you sure are good at that dad knows
pickin huh yeah mister you're getting
good at that nose-picking her lady oh my
love dies water see so then she got in
trouble because she was actually Master
Assassin Latasha Romanov the USSR and
she would use nose-picking to then shove
her finger into the the brain of the
person that she was picking the nose up
my eye is like bleeding water you're
tired
hey I've stuck through some watery eyes
before so you can do a little of your
own and she decided she wanted to be a
buffalo so she started eating lots of
string cheese okay yeah but then she
realized that was a really stupid
[ __ ] idea
so she abandon that plan and then
continued her assassination route and
then she was discovered by the FBI and
then she went on a trip to Alaska where
she was gonna you know with the amazing
markiplier where she was gonna uh uh
pick his nose to death but he mark Lowry
was too smart and then it's your turn
was it Rhonda man no it's Latasha
Romanov now Oh
Latasha then realized she was in Alaska
and so she became Sara peeling me and
that's all that happens there oh my eye
are you okay uh-huh
there are no brakes on this and I'm on
my way back I don't know if I am huh I
don't think we're seeing eye to eye on
this issue that's funny cuz you can't
see out of your eyes I really can't I
know that actually has happened before
it's like on this very show that we're
doing like it's just like oh it's
bleeding yeah not very pleasant is it no
it's not but I tough through it so it's
not being such a big baby yeah I've got
one I'm still building okay I've got
tons of food like I got tons and tons of
cans of food so we should be good for
old good long while oh I made my
supports too huh
why did you do that it's okay I can
reconcile you can yeah I'm getting the
stone back by breaking it with this this
here pickaxe is yoga
there's your pickaxe yeah yeah yeah you
know what this game this Josh I keep
calling this a show but I mean the
steers have devolved to know you and I
[ __ ] around while not getting
anything accomplished I'm actually
getting a lot accomplished oh I guess we
are getting things accomplished so we're
kind of deviating from the original
show's plan no one's gonna watch this
why would they wash it I just like this
accomplishing stuff if you guys know you
do you guys don't know but I mean if you
guys saw like us eat dinner it's like
this but we're eating and anytime we
hang out it's just this but we're doing
something pretty much exactly this it's
always but maybe sometimes a little more
raunchy when we get into it because oh
man like the conversations we sometimes
get into like in the middle of a crowded
Cracker Barrel and we're talking like
something shoving its dick up something
or other I don't remember you remember I
don't know half of what we do but I mean
like in the middle of a crowded family
restaurant we're just like [ __ ]
around laughing way too [ __ ] loud
where are you are you bad I'm inside
yeah there's another dog I'm gonna seal
up the mine good doggy won't die how
much wood do you have um not a lot I'm
just gonna plug up this hole because I'm
throwing our supports up so I'm gonna
have to get more stone or so can you
hurry the F ass up I'm working hard
you're not working hard enough I'm
working so hard for the money honey
really really baby oh god there's
nothing done here what do you mean
another done no this is exactly what we
left it as no it is no I'm gonna go
watch your channel by clicking on the
annotation on your face and observe how
you do nothing to contribute to this
game world I am going to shoot your LP
in the face my LP your LP no not my LP
Oh take that your LP okay anyway so
we're building this up at dirt
yes or wood and then filling on top of
it with dirt yeah I'm gonna build price
and more supports that make sure it can
support the two layers up hold up hold
up hold up hold up hold up hold up hold
up hold straight the pulled no sup hold
oh oh yeah that whole nighttime things
happening yeah whatever who cares let's
stay out in the night let's kill each
other let's shoot each other in the face
with gun yeah at least block up the door
to the inside dude come in no all right
you know we should prepare evacuation
procedures because this is gonna be the
last episode we record jump in hunt so
we got a store all our stuff that we
don't want to lose reminder especially
because uh yeah you're not on the server
although they can keep my stuff you just
store your stuff yeah I've got lots of
food so much food
I gots none you want a can of pasta
sounds so good you gotta work for it
baby I work hard for the money you want
them pie days delicious
I'm just chewing right through the can I
want it well get over here I'm trying to
give it to you you did try to light it
up light it up up up what does that even
mean
I think it's a song is it well then you
can't sing it I wasn't I was wording it
wording it is the same thing as singing
it in the eyes of the law I'm going to
brighten it in the vertical way okay I
don't care get in here get in here I
thought we were staying out here no get
in here gonna stay out there why would
we stay out there you just said I stay
out here oh we got an execute the
evacuation protocol that means you got a
store your stuff
oh yeah exactly I all my metal D stuff's
going in here good I'm gonna miss you
metal D stuff you should cuz I'm gonna
steal it
ah talk dirty to it while you're not
good luck config cooker try to say how
does it quit arguin you look - you know
that out there you're quitting Nick
that's pretty much what I said
I'm need to make more torches Oh some
more girls there isn't paper cloth right
what cloth yeah I just used all of my
cloth to make 68 torture it's good use
of my time right sounds looking terrible
well yeah that's good we should probably
uh get inside I am inside oh you are ho
k alright block up that door
well okay in case you know you never
know they could come up here and they
get bad right through all right I'll go
into my inventory still okay you do that
I'm gonna try to make sure the
downstairs is okay expect to be hip
night hip night who's hip night I don't
know I stole it quote from Jane's on the
Bob what I've probably even got the
quote wrong but I still stole it from
there what it's a show what it's a movie
what it's a green bean what what what no
not really
they're not good ah I lied to you I'm
here like storing my stuff's is hang on
I gotta get this yeah okay there we go
all right most of my important stuffs is
his store did Sid stuff this is my
stuff's is is stored good okay so we are
all out of time once again it is been a
lovely day spent with you Wade we are
getting a surprising amount accomplished
we are we really are you need food Wade
uh you can I'll just do it the next one
now you get the dog here eat this eat it
eat it I want to see you eat it you eat
that dog food oh really did it do it
it's right yeah that just doesn't do
much yeah eat it no it's good is it yeah
good you want to do this water with it
you another oh this can of dog food on
the floor there you didn't pick it up
that's enough I'll be fool go eat
another one yeah get on your knees you
need one more you will Martin I don't
even
I still ever seen
thereby this
and the volume turned way up
they're probably breaking in right now
that's where I'm gonna end that episode
like right there there's gonna go into
the outro just boom bang out in the
upper oh man that was oh we also are
getting in hey you want some of this
reloading oh I was gonna shoot him we're
not recording are we no I'm still going
just for the thing in the thing you know
the thing
oh my inventory is all empty did okay
good I'm gonna leave mine will be fine
on me right yeah it should be fine okay
good
no I'm just gonna leave it there is
there anything else we can do is think
we're good
why Nigel why not away hide away I
realize we could still play that game I
wish I could do I've talked with the
developers about it I've gone with their
technical support they can't figure out
why I can't play the game it's really
weird I mean I'm like I love that game
and I'm I like met them in person I met
the developers in person and they still
can't figure out why the hell I can't
play their freaking game can you like
uninstall it I've done it I've done
different computers it's like my account
is officially bored weird I know
very weird like very so I don't know I
don't get it
whatever so that's all for this alright
alright but we done be done
hi I'm leaving the saver okay bye